- All right, everybody.
Let's close out with one last story
to give you all the feels.
This is what I'm liking.
(jazz music)
(audience claps)
As a mama, there is nothing
like watching my kids smile
and light up when they see me.
It's adorable.
It's awesome.
And it makes you feel good.
Well, one mom decided to
record her son's reactions
when she picked him up from daycare.
She captured him nearly
every day for five years
and it's straight up adorable and awesome.
Watch this.
- [Teese] Hi, Jacks.
(baby screams)
Hi, Jacks.
(mother laughs)
- Hey, Jacks.
Okay, okay.
(baby screams)
(baby laughs)
- Mommy!
(shoes tapping)
(Kelly laughs)
(audience claps)
- I love it.
I kid you not,
that is literally my son Remi.
He's the same way.
It makes me feel so good.
We have Teese and her five
year old son, Jackson,
on the line right now.
What's up, y'all?
(audience cheers and claps)
(Teese laughs)
I'm not even kidding, Teese,
That's my, my daughter does not do that,
but my son does that.
Every time I get home,
he just gets so excited.
It makes you feel so good!
- Yeah, it's the best feeling ever.
(Teese laughs)
- Oh, it is.
Tell us how it all got started.
Did you just, yeah, he got it.
(Kelly laughs)
Did you notice when you
went to go pick him up
that he started doing it all the time?
(Kelly laughs)
- Yeah so he started daycare fairly young.
He was about two months old.
(Jackson laughs)
And I started to notice
that he would have this
really excited squeal
and you know, for a little
baby to show all that emotion,
I thought it was the cutest thing.
So I started to record
the pickups every day.
(Jackson laughs)
And then for his fifth birthday,
I decided to just kind of
compile all of my favorite videos
into a reel.
And I decided to post it right
before his birthday party
on Twitter, on my, you
know, small followers.
And I was, you know, busy with the party.
Didn't really think about it.
And then at the end of the day,
I had all these text messages
saying the video was like,
blowing up, it was going viral
and then it just went from there.
- Oh my God.
Do you have a question?
He's like,
(Kelly laughs)
Did you know that you're famous Jackson?
That everybody loves you?
- Yes, I'm famous!
(Kelly laughs and claps)
(audience claps)
- I love him so much.
(indistinct)
- Aw, Jackson, we love you.
Keep gettin' excited.
I promise you, you make your mama's day.
Keep being excited every time.
(audience claps and cheers)
Thank you so much, Jackson.
Thank you, Teese!
- Thank you!
I'm liking your post right now.
(heart dings)
(audience claps)
And that's not all.
Our season long partner,
Pilot Pen, makers of friction,
the go-to erasable pen of
the Kelly Clarkson show
want to celebrate those
creating fearlessly,
just like you ma'am.
So they're gonna give
you a thousand dollars.
How's that sound?
(audience cheers and claps)
(Kelly claps)
- Wow!
Thank you!
- That is something you
can now get excited about.
(audience cheers)